does the screenwriter find themselves an
agent or does the work find them the
agent in a perfect world the way that
we'd love to see it work is your script
comes in as a finalist for the nickel
every manager and agent in town reaches
out to you boom you have a manager a
name or an agent right you win the UCLA
contest very much the same scenario
Austin Film Festival that is not always
the scenario the scenario for most
writers is that they're gonna work
pretty hard to find the rep it's usually
gonna be manager first because managers
really today service talent scouts for
the big agencies and it's gonna take a
lot of work a lot of diligence and a lot
of consistency to find that rep so for
example one of my writers who just got
signed a couple of months ago had this
list of the managers and agents that she
would approach every time she would
finish a script and it was vetted and
she knew it was ready to go she had
placed top three and final drafts some
years ago but nothing materialized rep
wise and so she had finished a new
script that she was really excited about
and we were sitting across from one
another and going through her list and
she said ah do I have to send a script
to this manager again I've sent him like
five scripts and he doesn't like
anything and I said yeah you send it to
everybody that's just what we do and
three weeks later that manager became
her manager who's now sending her out on
an extreme amount of generals and
showrunner meetings because finally the
thing came aboard that he felt okay I
knew you're a writer I knew you're good
I know that you're consistent now you
wrote something great so oftentimes it
ends up being the writer finding the rep
rather than the rep finding the writer
even though we'd like to think that in a
perfect world you know rep would come
knocking on your door and truth it's a
referral business so the best reps and
the best relationships are forged
through referrals where somebody will
say hey my friend Joe just finished this
great script you should read it
because really that's what the industry
trusts were were highly social industry
so if you can get those referrals which
is why you foster relationships those
are priceless it's much easier to get a
rep through a referral than it is
through a contest placement unless
you're winning that contest
or through the blacklist and
you get the coveted 9 rating on the
blacklist so really it's about working
those relationships so that those
referrals will be in place when you have
that script that's ready to share
you